what i'm going to do in this video is
attempt to create an implementation of
the insert insertion sort algorithm that
we talked about in the last video and
i'll do it as a python function so i'll
call the python function
insertion
insertion sort and it will take in a
list
so list is its parameter and the
function definition someone would have
to pass list as an argument
and
let's what we're going to do is we're
going to step through each of the each
of the slots in the list i guess we
could call it that way so let's say for
index in
and range we could start at the left
most slot in the list so we could just
say length len just means is short for
length so length of the list so what
this would do
this would start index so let's say the
list has four elements in it then len
list
this right here would be four would
evaluate to four range of four would
produce a list that has the elements 0 1
2 3 in it and so index would be able to
step through the different indices for
this list right over here and we could
do it that way but you might remember
you might remember from the previous
video that when you're doing the
insertion sort it doesn't actually make
sense to start at the very left most
element because there's nothing to
compare it to to the left so we can
actually just start at the second to the
leftmost element and the leftmost
element is the zeroth item so we can
start at the first item so now if if the
list has a length of four this right
here will produce one two three so it
would one would be the second to the
leftmost element two would be the next
one to the right three would be the last
one remember we always start our indices
at zeros the zeroth term is the leftmost
element in a list so fine we can step
through that and let's get the value of
right at that point in time of the
element that is at that
index so that way we don't have to keep
finding it value is equal to list
list index and this by no means is going
to be the most efficient implementation
of even insertion sort it's just going
to be my best try
writing it in real time in a way that
hopefully hopefully you might be able to
understand it so value is just the item
in the list at each of those indexes
that we're now going to compare to all
of the items to the left of it
and what i want to do what i want to do
is compare value i want to compare value
to each item to the left of it so let's
let's define a variable i unless this
let's let this be the index of the
things that i want to compare value to
and right from the get go i want to
compare value to the thing that is left
of it so i should have one lower of an
index than index
so index
minus one so this is the index of the
item that is directly left to it but
we're going to keep taking i lower and
lower so we can keep comparing value to
things further and further to the left
and so what we want to do is we're going
to want to keep
we're going to want to keep comparing
further and further left until i has
gotten all the way to the beginning of
the list and i has gotten all the way to
the beginning of the list when it is
equal to 0. so what we want to do is we
want to perform this while i is greater
than or equal to zero because if we keep
taking i lower and lower and lower we're
going further and further to the left in
the list we don't want to try to perform
it when i is you know further is a
negative number that'll just start doing
crazy things so while i is
is greater than or equal to zero what
i'm going to do is i'm going to keep
pushing i'm going to keep pushing i
further and further to the left so let's
try it this way so the first thing i
want to do we've already pushed it to
the left once
so let's compare let's compare so if
value if value is less than
is less than the
this thing keeps saying syntax error
because it's waiting for me to keep
typing if value is less than
the item that is now at index i so the
item at index i
list
the item at index i is this right here
so if it is less than that
let's shift the item that's over here
let's shift it one to the right
so the right slot is i plus one
and i can't just say it's index because
remember i'm going to keep pulling i and
lower and lower and lower so because
right now index is i
right now i is index -1 in the first
pass through this while loop but i'm
going to as you'll see in a second i'm
going to keep lowering i so it always
won't be one left of index so i'm going
to say whatever wherever i is
let's take the spot 1 to the right of i
one to the spot of one to the right of
that so that's i plus ones is its index
and let's replace that with whatever's
at
list
let's and whatever's at i at slot i so
we've essentially taken this thing right
over here whatever whatever number was
there and we are putting it in the slot
that is one to the right of it
and then and actually the way we're
setting up that algorithm whatever's
there is actually going to be well i
won't talk about that we'll step through
it and see how it all plays out
and then we can shift value we can shift
value to the left so whatever was in
this slot right over here will be
replaced by value
so list
i will equal value
so
one way to think about let me write a
comment here shift
what
was
what shift
number
in slot in slot
i to
slot i plus one or you could say bucket
i plus one i guess that's the one way to
think about it and then you could say
shift number
right let me call it this way shift
number right in slot
let me write it this way shift number in
slot i
right to slot i plus one
and then over here we are shifting
here we are shifting
shift
shift value
left
into
slot
i and so if you remember what we did in
the last video this is exactly
describing it we're comparing value to
the thing to the left of it if it's less
than it then whatever number was in the
in that box to the left of it the slot
to the left shift it to the right and
then swift shift value to the left and
now compare value to something one lower
than that so we want to decrement i we
want a lower i decrement is just
increment down so i is equal to i
minus i is equal to i minus 1 and then
we'll perform the loop over again we'll
perform the loop over again and now
value will be compared now i is 2 to the
left of index compare it to that if it
is less than it shift that to the right
and shift value again to the left
now what if we have the situation where
value where value is not less than the
item that you're comparing it to well if
it's not less than the item that you're
comparing it to and that that means that
value is already going to be in the
right place and it all it also means
that you're done that you don't need to
shift value any more to the left and you
don't have to shift any of the stuff to
the left anymore to the right so then we
are we are done
and i think this could work unless i've
made some silly mistakes so let's try to
see if i can get this if i can if this
actually works as a sorting algorithm so
let me save it
insertion sort and let me run it
all right so i didn't have any at least
you know syntax mistakes syntax just
means the actual you know the actual
characters i use i didn't forget to put
a colon here or greater than sign or i
didn't it was actually able to
process this interpret this right over
here but let's see if it actually works
so let me define
a list
let's say it is 7
or 2 and let me put another 3 in there
so that is a
and then let me see this is the moment
of truth insertion sort
of a
let's see what happens so remember we're
sorting it in place this function
doesn't return anything but it should
take whatever list that was and had
changed up all of the elements so that
now they are in order so this is the
moment of truth let's see what a looks
like
there you go it is sorted so i don't
think i made any any major mistake so
there there you go you have insertions a
version of insertion sort